build mastery over a specific target and, you know, become familiar with an application
at a, I almost just said it at an intimate level, like me and this application are like
getting down and dirty.
It's 9 p.m.
Um, all right, dude, we got some, uh, we got some news today, huh?
Yeah.
Yeah, man.
There's a, there was a lot that went on this week.
It must be just beginning of the month, you know?
Yeah.
You want to take one or should I?
Yeah, sure.
I mean, I'll take the, the first, the first big thing, um, which is that, uh, unfortunately
uh, port swigger creators of burp suite.
They have decided that they are going to be ending their, I think it was weekly, the weekly
newsletter, uh, the daily swig.
Maybe it was daily.
Yeah.
It was called the daily swig, but yeah, yeah, no, it's sad to see that, man.
I, uh, you love to see quality content being put out and aggregated in the bug bounty space
and the cybersecurity space.
So sad to see them go, but yeah, I definitely, definitely understand it is hard to keep up
with the pace of the industry for sure.
A hundred percent.
I mean, I think if anything, we've learned that this is definitely a full-time job at
times.
Yeah, man.
Yeah.
It definitely takes, I mean, even just the aggregation of stuff like that.
I feel like every time I'm looking through Twitter, I'm, I'm, you know, on the clock trying
to aggregate some cool stuff.
And luckily we had a nice little planning session last week and we've got some, we've got some
content planned out a little bit.
We were very organized recently.
Yeah.
So hopefully things are a little bit easier, but I could definitely see how trying to do
this every day would, uh, definitely wear you down a little bit.
That was definitely a grind.
Sad to see it go, but on, on other news, they have been killing it.
Portsweger has in the research area.
Do you see these three links that I put in there about the, um, the, uh, new access S vectors
that they're coming out with?
I did.
These are really, really awesome.
Um, and I'm just thinking about a couple of different scenarios, like literally in the last
week or two that, uh, XSS is that were like really, really hard to exploit that would have
probably been a lot easier to exploit with these tips.
Yeah, for sure, man.
I hadn't seen any of this before.
And the one that kind of blows my mind, we'll link them down for you guys in the description,
but I'm specifically talking about the one February 27th where, uh, he was talking,
he has an, a, an a tag with an H ref, the H ref ref contains percent zero a, and then your
JavaScript payload alert one.
And then when you click it, it has an on click as well and sets the protocol to JavaScript.
So then I guess, so I guess what happens here, the order is the on click triggers, sets the
protocol of the H ref to JavaScript.
And then when the H ref gets triggered after the on click finishes, then the protocol has
already been updated to JavaScript.
And then the actual executed H ref is JavaScript colon percent Oh, a alert one.
Yeah.
It's super, super cool.
It's a super cool attack vector.
Cause I think all the time you see like eight and a link that you have more access to than
you do like an arbitrary element.
Um, and this is just a really great attack vector because it sort of puts another spin
on ways to sort of pop that XSS that are outside of the standard vectors.
I think, I think this one, I think this one would probably be most helpful if you've got like
one of those laughs.
That's just kind of annoying because, um, you know, obviously he's in, inside the on click
handler, there's a protocol L you know, piece being used.
Um, you know, so you're, you're assigning a variable already inside of on click.
So you, you've already got JavaScript execution.
Um, but the scenario where this would be most helpful, I think is payload obfuscation to
get past a laugh and, and kind of, um, do it a little bit more sneakily in that, in that
way.
Yeah, for sure.
I know that like a lot of laughs are going to block on click maybe just by default, but
if you have access to on click and it's much, it's like a very sensitive laugh, like you,
like you mentioned, that's probably a great, um, attack vector where you basically set
this protocol to JavaScript and then HTTP links, uh, from that page are executed like JavaScript
basically.
Yeah.
No, the one that, that just blows my mind is, um, I don't, I don't know how to tell you
which one it is.
I guess it's the one that ends in seven, zero, six, eight, eight, um, Joel in the doc.
It's, it's the one that, that has a script tag and then location dot protocol equals JavaScript.
And then like inside the, the script tag, there's like a comment that has,
Oh no.
Yeah.
No, that's just the example URL.
Oh, dude.
No way.
That's the example URL.
Yeah.
And so somebody actually on the, on the, on the earlier tweet that you, we were just talking
about somebody replied and mentioned that oftentimes they see that, um, there'll be a check that
the eight, that the href location has to have either an HTTP or an HTTPS on it.
But if you put two slashes at the end, it works fine.
Yeah.
No way.
So I think that's why in that, in that payload that you see, you can see, it's like a HTTPS
colon slash slash example.com.
Then you have your download payload and then you end in two slashes.
Yeah.
So then it, it updates the per the protocol, right?
And that's why the, the percent OA is necessary there.
It updates the protocol.
Wow.
Okay.
This is sick guys.
You definitely got to go open up this, this payload.
I thought it was cool before I understood it.
And now I understand it.
This is nuts.
Um, definitely check out this one, this tweet ending in 70688 in the description from
Portswigger research, because essentially what's happening here is it's reassigning the
protocol.
And then if I'm getting it correct, Joel, it's commenting out from a example all the way to
the new line.
And then it's executing after that, uh, because that new line bumps it down to the next line
inside the JavaScript and then it executes alert one and comments out the rest of it.
Yeah.
So I'm not sure like whether or not like,
the comment has to be within that script tag.
You know what I mean?
I think that they're saying like, if you go to that URL, no, no, no, it's not, it's not
that, it's not that, that URL there, but, but you know, when it updates the JavaScript
protocol there and it becomes JavaScript colon slash slash, right?
And then slash slash is a, is a, is a comment in JavaScript.
So then it's commenting out all the way into the percent OA and then it's bumping down a
new line and then executing alert, I think is what's happening.
Super interesting.
They actually, it's funny.
People mentioned that they made a, they have a typo in their payload here.
They did percent zero a, uh, and they tied it in with alert, but it needs to be percent
zero alert instead of percent zero alert.
Yeah.
So it's going to execute a function called alert.
Alert one.
You got like a, like a hick hacker there.
Alert, alert one.
And then I fired the alert one.
Firing alert one.
And then the last one, it's all right.
Cause I'm from Virginia and I say y'all.
So I, I'm just making fun of my own, my own culture here.
Um, yeah, no.
So the last one was this, uh, this research that they did a navigation dot navigate.
And apparently navigation is a, uh, is sort of a, uh, uh, experimental object within Chrome.
Um, so that's another method to get, to get an XSS to pop if you have access to it.
Yep.
And again, somebody in the comments, uh, on the replies on this mentioned, uh, it, it's
a little bit of an odd attack scenario because you're basically executing JavaScript from
JavaScript, but, uh, Portswigger research replied and they mentioned that it's basically
just like another, uh, like, yeah, it's like your target, depending on what you're dealing
with, depending on the page, there's a lot of different scenarios that you're going to
be exploiting, some of them might end up hitting navigate dot navigate.
And if you have a string that can lead into that, then you can pop an XSS in a, in another
different way, which is, uh, yeah, just great knowledge to keep in the, in the back of your
brain, put it in your notepad, put it in your sticky notes.
Yeah, for sure.
I, I appreciate, uh, Portswigger research is throwing us here because, you know, whenever
we're writing a tool or something like that, their, their cheat sheet that they have is a
really good resource for knowing where all of the sources and syncs are.
Um, so yeah, definitely shout out to them for that.
Yeah.
Super, super dope.
Um, Gareth, Gareth Hayes, um, who wrote Hackverter, great burp suite plugin.
Uh, if you're not familiar with it, Hackverter is like, I don't even know how to describe it.
It's kind of like the decoder tool that's built into burp suite, but on steroids.
So you can put in little tags that basically automatically encode and decode different types
of texts.
Yeah, so helpful.
It's super great for you, for your research and your payload testing.
You don't have to like encode something, send it, change it, encode it, send it.
You just type it in plain text and put it in little tags that'll encode it the right way
and you're good to go.
One of the things that I, that I've noticed sort of about this, and this is just sort of
a general hacking principle is like, if you're trying to write an exploit for something and
you are just trying to get the proof of concept, you know, in place to prove to yourself that
there's a valid vuln, um, you gotta make that, that, what is it like iteration cycle, you
know, the time it takes for you to try one attempt, you gotta minimize that as much as you
possibly can.
Cause that just is as, as much friction as you can remove from that as possible.
Your brain is spending less time thinking about, okay, now I gotta encode this and I gotta
encode that and blah, blah, blah.
And it's focusing more on, okay, this is the big picture of the exploitation that's happening.
And, uh, I think that's absolutely pivotal.
So hack converter really does that, that well and allows you to kind of, um, without having
to put too much thought into it, make sure that your payload's getting encoded properly.
Yeah.
This is, um, it's taken me back to our conversation about automation and sort of where you draw that
line in terms of this is something I should automate versus this is something I should just
test manually and find the bug and submit it.
Yeah, absolutely, man.
Since we're on the topic of, of Gareth Hayes, I figured I'd give a shout out here to his
JavaScript for hackers ebook.
Um, yeah, the guy just puts out constantly amazing JavaScript, uh, payloads and discoveries
and research.
And I've only read like the first chapter of the book, but in the first chapter, you can
just tell how much he loves JavaScript.
He's like, man, I just, you know, it's not about the hacking for me.
It's just about knowing everything about JavaScript.
I just slapped my mic.
Hopefully that didn't get, make too terrible sound, but he's just, you know, he's so enthusiastic.
He's like, I just want to know every single thing about JavaScript.
Um, and that's the kind of guy you want writing a book called JavaScript for hackers for sure.
So, um, definitely worth every penny of 20 bucks, um, that the book costs.
And, and yeah, I mean, the, the other thing is that, and this is sort of a rant that I won't
go too far down, but, um, it, it's such a good, it's such a good and such an important practice
to invest in yourself as a professional in any industry and even more so in the cybersecurity
industry.
So getting, um, educational materials like this book, um, getting certs that are going to
add value like the OSCP and offensive security products.
Um, that is, that is absolutely worth every penny you put into it.
So, um, definitely go ahead and pick up this book by Gareth Hayes.
Yeah, absolutely.
I think it's one of those sort of, you, you know, you might read like the whole book and
only pull like a couple like key, really useful things, but those key useful things are going
to be really, really useful and they're going to be super useful down the line.
You're going to like pull on that knowledge constantly.
Um, and it might not even be immediately apparent as you're reading it, like, oh, this is something
that's super useful, but I'm, I'm almost certain that as you're hacking, you're going to pick
up on some things and you're going to be like, oh, I read it.
It's almost like, it's almost like the butterfly effect, you know, inside of hacking, inside
of knowledge is just kind of getting that knowledge, knowing how all these various pieces work
together, you start to be able to craft a better picture of how the JavaScript engine's working
and how, um, all the different pieces fit together.
Um, and so definitely, yeah, definitely has a lot of value.
Yeah.
He also mentions in the description that, uh, there is, he, he covers this thing called JSFuck,
uh, which is something that, that I have messed around with quite a bit, but essentially it's
building JavaScript payloads using only plus open and close square bracket, open and close
parentheses and the exclamation symbol.
So just that, that set of what, two, four, six characters.
It's nuts.
It's, it's super, super cool.
If you want to dig into it to see how it actually works, you, you definitely can, but I, I totally
recommend buy this book.
Have you, have you, like, I still have no idea how that works.
Do you have any remotest idea how that works?
Or have you just kind of played with it?
Yeah.
So it's essentially, if you, if you think about like how JavaScript implicitly converts
things, if you have like two, two parentheses, uh, like that's like calling something that
will evaluate to a, like a string called function.
Yeah.
Okay.
And from there you have indexes.
So if you do like a string function index zero, that's the letter F.
And so you can build out an entire alphabet that is based on that, or you can do offsets
from care codes and yeah, it's, it's absolutely crazy.
Do you have to get to an eval statement or something or?
No, because you can run it as a function.
So it's at a certain point you could just return stuff essentially.
Oh my gosh, dude, that's crazy, man.
Yeah.
I, I definitely want to go in after this and kind of suss out exactly how it kind of
gets to works out all the different pieces.
Cause that's, that's crazy.
I have used it before though, actually in like an actual exploitation context, there was just
a really tight laugh and I knew I was in the, the JavaScript context.
So I was just like, boom, I'm just gonna, just gonna encode it with this.
And, and there you go.
Yeah.
All about WAF bypasses today.
Yeah, man.
I don't know.
To be honest, I haven't really come up against a WAF in a while.
Um, most of the excesses that I've, I've kind of been popping lately have.
Yeah.
I mean, most are on the main application and you're not really sticking a WAF in front
of the main application a lot of times.
So.
Yeah, I know exactly what you mean.
Um, I have seen a couple recently and usually it's not like a homegrown WAF.
Um, yeah, but there are definitely still WAFs out there.
I think it's starting to consolidate into just a couple mainstream ones where they just don't
use a WAF at all and they just do sanitization on their inputs and call it a day.
Yeah.
Well, I mean, it's the better way.
I feel like, I feel like a WAF is a little bit of a safety net.
Um, but yeah, it definitely takes performance off of your application.
So, you know, if you're talking about some of these bigger, bigger targets that need performance
as, as a part of their business use case, it's not super, super feasible to do that.
A hundred percent.
All right.
What else we got in here?
You want to talk about, uh, Rogin's, Rogin's?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So for those who don't know, Rogin, AKA Uranium238, uh, he's pretty old school hacker.
Uh, I actually work with him and, uh, he started a company called, uh, Ophion, Ophion.
I'm not sure how to pronounce it, but, uh, Ophion Security.
He's been doing a lot of really awesome security research and work through that company.
Um, including, I think there's a B-Sides talk coming up pretty soon that he's going to be
given about, um, I think about GitHub stuff, but he did a blog post recently about finding
code space, uh, secrets on GitHub through, I believe through the import feature, which I
don't know if we talked about this last week, but I know there was another bug, uh, on GitLab.
I think it, yeah.
That was an XSS popped through, uh, a repo import.
Yeah, actually, I think this one is, is a, is a security advisory is kind of how he pops
it.
Oh, is there?
Yeah.
And then I think you might be confusing it with one of the other ones.
Hopefully we don't have to bleep out any of that.
Hopefully he's fine with us talking about other, other work he's done.
But, um, yeah, this one's a, a, a temporary fork and I'm actually a little bit salty at
him because like, I, I looked at this target at a live hacking event, like earlier last year.
And, uh, and I missed this and not only did he find this, but he also escalated it by hitting
a GitHub actual, an actual GitHub repo and an organization repo, which is, yeah.
Just such, yeah, that's what it was.
Yeah.
And that's just so big brain.
Like he, he takes this and then applies it straight to GitHub and ends up being able to
pull a, a, a token for the user gh dash containers dash bots, which has a bunch of like read,
write access to internal repositories and stuff like that.
So that's, that's pretty sick.
And I will say for any of you that are interested in GitHub as a target, um, code spaces is a
super fascinating target.
I, I, I, I didn't love hacking on GitHub before this past life hacking event that we did with
them.
Um, but they, they sort of, you know, nudged us a little bit towards code spaces during that
event.
And I was so glad they did because it's such a cool, it's such a cool, um, feature and there's
a lot of scope, um, in there without going too much into detail about, about the vulns.
Uh, there's a lot of scope in there where you can, you know, do funky stuff, especially.
And this is another thing that I wanted to shout out the podcast about GitHub.
Um, if anyone's just hacking any GitHub related products, um, there's one concept that results
in so many vulns that GitHub cannot do.
Um, they cannot get rid of it for legacy reasons.
If you fork a repo and you commit to the forked copy of the repo, then that commit hash can
be accessed on the original repos tree.
Um, and that just results in so many vulnerabilities, uh, because, you know, anytime they're trying to
do repository level access controls, you can fork.
And then your malicious, you know, fork your, your malicious commit that you've, you've pushed to your
fork that, that can be accessed, um, via a commit hash in the original, um, repository.
So I know I've talked to their security team a little bit.
They're doing their best to kind of keep those vulns to a minimum, but it's definitely a cool
trick that you need if you're going to go hack GitHub products.
That's a super interesting attack scenario.
So basically if you say you, you, you find a bug that's referencing an arbitrary commit hash,
you can fork it, make some changes, provide your own commit hash.
That's from your fork and it would work.
Well, it's, um, I, it's not exactly like that.
So what, what it is, is it's when, for example, there's, you need to have specific content in a,
in a repo, right?
So let's say like you own a repo, Joel, right?
And I don't have right access to that repo.
I've only got read access, right?
But I do have the ability to fork.
So I fork your repo, right?
And I commit into my own repo.
Then I get the commit hash from that.
And I can craft a URL that starts with slash Joel, slash Joel Margolis slash vulnerable repo
slash my commit hash.
And it will show my commits content in your repo because my, my, uh, my repo is a fork of yours.
So it's, it's a, it's a real weird little, little trick that you can do.
That's just a part of that sort of deeper Git stuff that I don't understand.
But, um, Tom mentioned that to me once before.
And then I want to say the other guy's name was not an aardvark.
Um, I'll have to go see if I can look it up, but he's kind of a, uh, prolific GitHub hacker.
So, um, talk to him about that as well.
Yeah.
GitHub has a huge attacks, uh, service.
I, I remember I, I hacked on them a couple of years ago and I found a pretty cool, um, interesting
bug that was within one of their pre-release features.
So a lot of times they gate their pre-release features with these specific headers that you
have to send.
Yeah.
And otherwise, like if you hit the end point, it doesn't work at all.
And I thought that was a great attack surface because it would be stuff that most people
probably haven't tested or looked at.
And sure enough, um, I was able to, uh, find a really cool bug in there.
I don't actually know if it's a resolved yet, but I'll have to look it up and see.
Maybe we can talk about it.
Yeah, for sure.
Definitely, definitely.
Let me know about that.
That sounds like a good one for the, for the reports section.
And I'm excited for the report section today.
Um, we're going to have two of the guys that I mentee come on and kind of talk about their
reports.
I, that are my mentees that I mentor, uh, come on and talk about some of some cool reports
that they've found.
Um, so it should be cool to see what kind of stuff they come up with.
I saw that in the doc, so I'm pretty, I'm pretty pumped to hear about what they found
and, and hear about the whole experience.
They're good bugs.
One of the guys right now is, is working on a bug that's like just phenomenal.
And I think he's, I think we've, we've got it to the point where it's going to be, it's
like, for sure, it's just going to take a crap ton of programming, but the exploit is
going to be like probably 300, 400 lines of code long.
So it's going to be, it's going to be a big one for sure.
That's awesome.
Cool.
Uh, onto the next.
Let's see.
Yeah.
Uh, we got Rezo's tweet and we got the live hacking standards.
Which one do you want to go?
Let's do, let's do the live hacking event standards.
Okay, cool.
Um, yeah.
So I, I just popped this on here because, um, one of the things that the community has
been talking about for a little while is hacker one's, uh, impact requirements for the live
hacking event standards.
Um, you know, they were saying that you need to have, I want to say it was like a 23 or 22,
uh, impact or above to get invited to the live hacking events.
And, um, and that was getting a lot of backlash because it's like, okay, well, do you literally
just not want us to report lows and mediums in order to, you know, get invited to the live
hacking events?
And I don't think that's what hacker one wants and, you know, talk to them about that.
But to be perfectly honest, man, I'm a little bit, uh, I'm, I'm a little bit on the fence
about their, their fix to this.
So go click on the link that I put in the doc.
And then if you scroll down, um, it's the one that says hacker one, uh, platform performers in the last
180 days.
Right.
And it still says researchers with more than 75% of submitted reports being higher critical.
So I guess that could be, I mean, that wouldn't be 22 impact.
Like if you submitted a bunch of, you know, 75% of your bugs are, are, you know, highs, then
you're at 25.
And then, you know, you've got maybe like a bunch of lows and that would pull you down
into like the 20 range.
And then, but still 75% of your bugs being higher critical seems a little bit, a little
bit, I mean, 75% of my bugs aren't higher critical.
Yeah.
I don't think mine are either.
Um, yeah.
You know, look, I definitely sympathize with hacker one on this.
I think they've been put in a tricky situation because in the early days of live hacking
events, it was very much so an organic sort of natural process where they basically just
wanted to invite top hackers, whatever that sort of means.
It's basically just people who perform well at events, um, who are consistent about finding
really good bugs who can provide a high impact and high value to the customers.
Um, that doesn't mean that you find a hundred percent criticals, a hundred percent highs
all the time.
It just means that that's sort of your skillset.
And that's not exactly an easy skillset to pinpoint.
The problem is that over time, over the years, the more events that they did, the more publicity
that they got, the more that they advertised and talked about the events, the more people
that wanted to come to the events.
Right.
Um, and so unfortunately they got into this situation where they have to explicitly define
how people get invited.
Right.
Because now if somebody doesn't get an invite, they go, well, why didn't I get an invite?
Well, yeah.
They need some sort of hard reason to explain why you did or didn't get an invite.
And that's very difficult to do.
And I think they tried to structure a lot of these rules around sort of like to get a
mimic of what they've been inviting already.
But, you know, if you write stuff like this, it's, you're going to back yourself into a corner
where now you have to invite these people or you can't invite these people.
Um, and I've seen personally, as well as with friends of mine who are really, really good
hackers who have been to tons of live hacking events who just don't get an invite because
they don't meet the criteria anymore.
And it's, uh, it's kind of unfortunate.
It's a tricky situation for hacker one because I think it's good to standardize it, but it's
also good to sort of keep that natural aspect to the hacking events.
Um, so they have, they have a little bit of a, they're, they're in a bit of a corner.
Yeah.
I totally agree.
And, and, you know, it's difficult, you know, I think too, but I, I think what they need to
kind of sit down and decide is what does the ideal hacker look like, you know, for this
specific, for this specific category, right?
Cause I think that's what they're trying to say.
Like what, what does the ideal hacker look like on our platform?
And for me, I don't think that's a hacker with 75% of their bugs being higher, higher
critical because I mean, at the end of the day, I don't
think you can do that without not reporting some lows and mediums.
And, and to be honest, um, you know, along the way, you know, you're, we're all looking
for highs and criticals.
That's the goal for sure.
But along the way, you, you hit some lows and you hit some mediums and they're not always
going to be chainable.
Sometimes they are, and that's great.
But, um, sometimes you've just got a bug that's just, this is never going to be chained,
but it needs to be fixed.
And, and, you know, there's some risk associated with it.
So I don't know, man.
I, I would still like, I would, I feel like maybe this criterion is a little bit, um, disconnected
from what the actual hacking process looks like and what it looks like to build mastery
over a specific target and, uh, you know, become familiar with an application at a, at a,
I'm, I almost just said in an intimate level, like me and this application are like getting
down and dirty.
Um, but yeah, no, uh, I think, you know, getting intimate with the application, you know, understanding
the, the ins and outs of it, some lows and mediums are gonna, are gonna pop up for sure.
So, um, yeah, it's an improvement for sure.
But in my opinion, it's not quite there still, but all the other categories look really good.
I know that there's gonna be some, some, uh, just sort of new to live hacking events section
where they talk about, uh, criticality, consistency, and community.
Those are the three C's that determine the MVH, uh, for the live hacking events.
Um, and so, you know, people that have demonstrated that within the community will earn themselves
up to five researchers and invite to the event.
And then also, um, I also liked to see up to 10 research from, uh, geolocation based selection.
So wherever the live hacking event is, if it's local to you, you'll have a chance of getting
an invite from just from that.
Um, and I think that's pretty cool.
Yeah.
I think, I think it's awesome to incorporate the local hackers and stuff.
A lot of these communities and the locations have really awesome local hacker communities and
local hacker groups and just local hackers in general, uh, that are undiscovered or, you
know, underappreciated talent.
And this is a great opportunity to sort of shine some light on that.
But, you know, again, that it opens the opportunity for a new person to get invited and then be
immediately excluded from the next one because they don't meet the criteria.
Right.
So yeah, I think that there is some room for refinement, but overall, it's great to see
them being so public about this and making adjustments to the rules.
I know that they've had these rules for quite a number of years, but I think this is maybe
the first blog post I've seen about it.
I think it's mostly just been in PDF form.
Um, yeah, but yeah, I think something that you mentioned and we'll probably talk more about
this is sort of the, you're not always going to submit highs and crits.
And our later discussion is going to be about full-time bug bounty hacking.
And I'm sure that somebody who acts full-time doesn't only submit highs and crits.
Right.
So yeah, man, let's, let's, let's hop onto that after we talk about Rezo real quick.
Cause I wanted to, he, he put out this tweet and I really like Rezo's tweets a lot of the
time and I think he, he adds a lot of value.
Um, but there's one that I just kind of had to throw a hot take out on, um, number two.
So I'll, I'll link it in the, in the description, but he says a bug bounty is a lot of luck,
but you control how many times you roll the dice.
Here's five ways to maximize your luck of finding a bug.
And he talks about number one, fuzzing all the things.
That's great.
I agree with that.
Number two, don't rabbit hole.
So I'm just going to read this out word for word.
Cause it's pretty short.
Don't spend more than a few minutes on any one thing until you finish the app.
Uh, Arch, Archangel, uh, Douglas, uh, does this extremely well.
The first time I saw him hacking, I was shocked at how fast he was testing the app.
Now.
Yeah.
I, I don't know, man.
What do you, what do you think?
I, I won't shoot my, my opinion out there first.
I want to get yours, yours and hear what you think.
Well, it's interesting.
Cause this was also something that I had put on my question sheet to ask you about
full-time hacking, but, um, I feel it's really hard to define this in like a hard set rule.
Um, because there are lots of times where we'd be hacking on a target and you'll feel like
this is not something that's worth pursuing, but I should keep hacking on it and keep poking
at it because I think that there might be something further here versus I need to optimize the amount
of time that I'm hacking on this.
So let me just move on and look at all the other features.
Cause I'm hacking on a big application.
Right.
Yeah.
I think, I think there is a balance.
I will say, I'm not going to come in too hot here, but I will say that I firmly disagree
with this.
I think, um, I think one of the ways, one of the things that changed about me, um, about
the way I hacked, uh, starting, I guess maybe 2021, um, was I hacked more in the, in the
past.
I focused more on like really trying to find everything and like getting all this coverage
and like really, you know, to be fairly honest, I was, it was before I had won an MVH and I
was shooting for the MVH.
You know, I wanted to kill everything, find all the bugs, you know, and dominate the event.
Right.
But when I stopped having that mentality, I actually won my MVHs.
Um, and the reason for that was because I was finding bugs that were more interesting, that
were deeper in the application and that were more impactful.
And, um, and I've mentioned this in the past.
This is one of my, one of my tips for, for live hacking events is you don't, we have two
weeks, you know, three weeks, maybe to, to attack these giant companies with these big
scopes.
You're not going to be able to cover everything.
So don't even try.
If you're on a team, maybe you could, you know, split stuff up and somebody could, you
know, go wide and, you know, an inch deep, but at the end of the day, to find the best
bugs, um, you're going to need to go deep.
And so I say rabbit hole, as much as you can try to find, try to find those, those weird
parts of the application that you can become a super expert on and, um, make sure that those,
those parts of the applications are very close to what the business values.
Um, because then once you become more intimately familiar, here I am again, me and me and this
application are getting it on, man.
Um, you know, once you become more, more intimately acquainted with the, uh, with the application,
you'll be able to see, you know, you'll find more impactful bugs that are, and they'll also
be a lot of, in my experience, they'll also be a lot of them.
Um, and so it's not necessarily that you're going to, you're not, you're going to be, you
know, that person that submits one super crit and is like super proud of it.
And, and that person's great.
And, and you know, that's definitely a valid strategy, but I think, um, you know, rabbit
holing, finding something very close to the business, um, data or the business value, and
then becoming a super expert on that is a better way to go in my opinion.
Yeah.
And I think you see this success story over and over again, where like you'll go to a hacker
program.
For example, you look at the leaderboard and it's like the rep is like one 50, one
80, 200, 250, 2,500.
And you're like, wait, like what, what happened between number two and number one?
Right.
And it's that number one has been hacking on this and going deep, right?
Like they've been going in, they've been taking lots of notes.
They've been finding all the little nuances.
They've been exploring the edge cases and the fringes of the application that nobody else has
been looking at and that's why the 2,000 rep are.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
And that, you know, that person definitely isn't the person that just went, you know,
an inch deep and a mile wide on the application.
Um, and, and to be fair, in the context of live hacking events, I think you also have to do
the trade-off of like, okay, well, I'm only going to be looking at this target for three
weeks.
Can I really become an expert on this in three weeks?
Um, and you know, that's going to be a know yourself sort of situation there.
But, um, for me, I, I've just been starting to hit those deadlines, man.
And we're like, you know, right as we're, as the event is getting close, I'm like, you
know, popping out some really good bugs the day before the event or even the day of the
event, because my, my knowledge of the application is starting to solidify and I'm really starting
to get it.
It's starting to click.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
And I think live hacking events are kind of a little bit of an edge case because you have
such that finite timeline.
And not only that you're racing against other like top elite hackers, right?
So everybody has the same scope.
Some people might be more familiar than others, but usually you kind of hope that it's a scope
that nobody has seen yet.
And you're all on sort of a level playing field, which also means that everybody's like racing
to be the best starting from the same place, right?
It's like a, you're on a track, right?
Everybody's at the starting line.
Who's going to make it to the end of first, who's going to have the best, you know, whatever.
And you have to really balance that.
Like how much time am I going to spend on this versus moving on?
How much time has somebody else spent on this?
Somebody already found this bug.
Is there a bug here that I haven't found yet that I'm going to spend all day finding that
maybe somebody else has found?
So I think there's a lot, a lot more involved in that decision.
It's complex, man.
Yeah, versus if you're just picking any target, you know, any public program, any private program,
you have a generally a pretty good idea that there's not going to be like that same caliber
of people focusing on it to the same level for the same period of time.
And if you take your time and you develop that familiarity, that intimacy, as you call it,
with the program, then you'll be able to get a little bit further than everybody else
because they're focusing on other programs.
Yeah, yeah, for sure, man.
Yeah, and I just want to clarify, you know, I really appreciate Rezo's tweets and, you know,
sharing knowledge and stuff like that.
And, you know, one way or the other, we're generating content, we're generating controversy,
so we're figuring out how to do this thing better together.
And just once over the other five things that he pointed out here.
So he says, fuzz all the things, you know, fuzz Vhosts, fuzz headers, fuzz parameters, fuzz everything.
And I definitely think that is one way of going about it.
I've seen a lot of people successful with that.
I don't know that I have, you know, really mastered that.
I think that I've got a lot of improvement to do in that area.
And I think Rezo probably does that a decent bit better than me.
Number three, so we're skipping number two, because, you know, not going to shout that one out.
Number three, dedicate time each day.
I totally agree with this.
You know, yeah, sometimes it's just, I mean, this is, I think this is the most correlatory thing to his original tweet at the beginning that says,
you control how many times you roll the dice.
Like, if you're getting in there and you're putting in the hours, you are 100% going to find a bug.
It's just going to take a lot of time.
Yep.
And it's not, and I think a lot of people, this is one thing I've been kind of talking about with my mentees lately, too.
I think a lot of people sort of fade out before they should on these sort of things.
Yeah, so share your leads, you know, hit up your local Joel and say, Joel, please help me with this lead.
And then invest time into learning new attacks.
I don't know, what do you think about that last one, Joel?
I mean, I think that's definitely true.
And I've seen Defparam sort of kill it with the request muggling stuff.
But yeah, there are a lot of bugs out there that are, you know, older that are still all over the place.
Yeah, I mean, listen, if you're listening to this podcast, you're already sort of, you know, you're there a little bit, right?
Like, you're investing in new attacks, you're learning, you're exploring, you're trying to consume sort of what's going on and stay up to date.
I think you see this so often where any industry, it doesn't have to be tech, it doesn't have to be bug bounty.
Anybody who falls behind and just stays stagnant and doesn't keep learning and stay on the front edge,
you're going to be that professor who's talking about, like, you know, back in 1990, you know, I invented TCP.
It's like, cool, man.
But like, what about like everything else?
I invented TCP.
Dang, dude, that, that, I feel like that's one of my professors at college, man.
There's just, hmm.
Everybody's had like at least one of those professors that's like, yeah, you know, back when I was in school, you know, we were inventing the internet.
It's like, oh, wow, that's cool.
Dawson, it just come out and I was, yeah.
And then they give you a homework assignment that's like some like old, antiquated, like not relevant.
Write this in cobalt, you know, like, no.
One thing that he does say in here is cache deception.
Have you played around with cache deception much?
I have found a lot of cache deception volumes and I always look for it.
I think it's because of Andre's influence, but I found out recently that not a lot of people are looking for that.
Is that, what do you think?
Yeah, I mean, caching is a huge, it's a huge problem.
It leaves so much room for problems just in every application.
I think there was a Twitter said just today about Loom.
Loom is some like, I don't know exactly what they do, but they mentioned that they were experiencing a problem where some users were being logged into other users' accounts.
And like, you would just like open Loom and you would be in someone else's account.
And I can almost guarantee this is a caching problem because...
Yeah, I use Loom.
I actually tried to log into my account yesterday and it was broken.
So I'm hoping nobody's logged into my account right now.
That's kind of crazy.
There you go.
So I'm sure their security incident response team is going crazy right now, trying to figure out who access what and all that kind of stuff.
But caching is one of those things that makes an application work way better and way faster and be just better as a whole.
But it also leaves a lot of risk for you to mess something up.
And I think it's one of those things that flies so underneath the radar that you might just like skip over the header, right?
You see like a cache control header or something and you're like, God, that's just, you know, delete that.
That's part of the normal response, whatever, move on.
And actually learning how cache control works and how cache deception works and request smuggling and the actual like details and fine details behind it.
You know, it's one of those investing time into learning new attacks.
At some point, it's probably a good idea to just sit down and focus, spend some focus time, spend a day, spend a couple hours and just play around with it in a controlled environment.
So you get a real good understanding for how something's working and then you can take it out into the real world.
Yeah, for sure.
I just noted it down.
Maybe we'll do an episode on web cache deception and web cache poisoning.
Those are both really interesting vulnerability types and I think are sort of under-researched.
So we'll put that on the queue.
Cool.
All right.
You want to talk about full-time bug money hacking?
Let's do it, man.
You got some questions here for me.
Oh, we do.
Hit me.
Okay, cool.
Well, let's just start with like, maybe you can tell me a little bit about what your day-to-day looks like.
Because at least for me, I'll give some context.
Like I'm a security engineer, so I work nine to five equivalent, you know, eight hours a day.
I start work, I finish work, and then I'm done with work.
So I'd be curious to hear sort of like, what does your day-to-day look like?
Do you work eight hours a day?
Do you work two hours a day?
Do you work weekends?
You know, I'd love to hear.
Yeah.
So, good question.
I'd say it varies a lot.
During the live hacking events, which happen every couple months, I'm hitting it pretty hard.
I'd say probably my minimum is eight, mostly looking more like a 10 or a 12-hour day during those events, just kind of grinding it out.
And, you know, the bounties are higher, the, you know, incentives are there, the bonuses are good.
So it's a good time to really like hit it hard.
Outside of that, normally after the live hacking events, I take some time off.
So normally that's a week or two.
I'd say maybe a total of like, I probably work maybe 10 months a year, maybe a little bit less.
And obviously that's not paid time off because I'm, you know, bugs equal money for me.
And so I have, I can pay myself from my LLC and then, you know, I can sort of have paid time off, but, you know, I'm not, I'm not actually making any money during that time, which is a little bit tricky.
So, yeah, that's, and then I'd say like the average day to day, I probably work maybe like six, six to eight when I'm not in the live hacking events.
So six to eight hours, not, not six o'clock to eight PM.
Yeah, just a casual, you know, 14 hours.
14 hour day, no biggie.
Yeah, as you do.
So you mentioned that like, especially during live hacking events, you're really on the grind.
You're really like pushing into it.
Do you take breaks?
Do you control your time in like a meaningful, purposeful way at all?
Or do you sort of just flow with energy level or?
Yeah, I kind of flow with the energy levels, man.
I'm not a big break taker.
It interrupts my focus.
I even get irritated when I have to get up and go to the bathroom.
I'm like, all right, let me just like finish this thing before I go.
Yeah.
So no, I, I, it's pretty much like a, it's almost always a full 10 hour like streak.
Um, and Mariah is amazing.
We've kind of built out for those of you that don't know, Mariah is my wife and, um, and during
the live hacking events, we've kind of hit a system where she understands that I'm going
to be very busy.
And she also understands that, you know, during the day, even though I'm not, you know, going to grab
lunch with her, like I normally do or something like that during a regular work day, um, that when I'm not
working, I will be entirely present with her, um, and with the other activities around.
But during the day, um, I'm totally focused.
So she brings me food.
I don't even realize I'm eating it half the time.
Uh, you know, she just plops it down and then I eat it and I just move along.
Um, very focused.
Um, don't take a lot of breaks and, and, but I know other people do.
Um, I, I want to say today's new Eric, you know, does a break every like 30 minutes or something
like that.
He'll get up and walk around.
So it's, there's definitely different strategies to it.
Cool.
Yeah, no, that's, uh, that's something that I definitely, I mean, especially during the
work day, I tend to sit down and just, I work like just until I have no energy left.
So that's, that's something I can definitely relate with.
Um, you mentioned that like, you know, bugs equals income, right?
And, um, I think that's probably the biggest hurdle for a lot of people who consider doing
bug bounty full-time is that you don't have that sort of stability.
There's no guaranteed income.
Um, it's all basically what you put in is what you get out.
And even that is sometimes you can put in so much and just get nothing out.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
Um, so how do you like, how do you manage your time and trying to optimize sort of your income?
So like, how do you pick what to hack on?
When do you choose to call it and move on and go to the next target or, um, sort of what
we talked about?
Like when do you decide that something is not worth going any deeper into and move on to the
next part of the application?
Yeah.
It's tricky, man, for sure.
I think, um, I think, you know, what I've been focusing on is largely determined by the
live hacking event.
So if I'm in a live hacking event, then I'm, um, you know, focusing on the target, obviously.
And when I'm not in a live hacking event, I have a couple.
Well, for one, I prioritized the hacker one challenges that come up because those are fresh
targets.
The bounties are normally like pretty decent.
Um, and so I'll, I'll go after those.
I hit one of those recently, but when there's no hacker one challenges and there's no live
hacking event, then I'm going after my, uh, uh, you know, old reliable program.
Um, I've, I've kind of landed on that being Instacart.
Um, finally get to shout them out on here.
Nice.
Um, great bounties, um, awesome team, very responsive.
Uh, yeah, just really enjoyed working with them.
So I hit them pretty hard.
Um, and yeah, when do I say, what do I call it?
When do I move on?
Most of the time, my attention is forcibly diverted, um, for a live hacking event.
So if I'm, if I'm in the middle of hacking on Instacart and I'm in deep and I've, you know,
in a certain section of the application, even if an H1 challenge comes up, I won't necessarily
jump on it.
Um, I'll stick with it and then, uh, I'll continue hacking that target until the live hacking
event comes up.
Um, the, the HackerOne World Cup is coming up, which I think I will prioritize over my
other stuff, which it did take some thought because, um, there are going to be, I think
the dupe situation is a little bit challenging there because, uh, there's not, they're not
doing a dupe period.
So it's just going to be a lot of people hacking on a target, but I've decided I'm going to
go, um, you know, for a little bit more obscure vulnerabilities, some, some specialties
of mine that I feel like most other people won't be able to find.
And hopefully that will, that will pay off pretty well.
Um, regarding your note on, you know, the stability piece, I don't, I don't think that
I, this is one of the things that I'm most grateful for in the world.
I don't know that I would have ever pulled the trigger on going full-time bug bounty if
Mariah hadn't pretty much insisted that I do it.
Um, because like, I don't know, I really do.
I'm someone that really naturally values that stability.
And so, um, you know, you definitely want to have some runway.
You definitely want to have, uh, I would say, you know, at least six months to a year of runway
in your, in your bank before you, um, kick off somebody I know who's about to go full-time
bug bounty is aiming for two years runway, which I think is a little, little excessive, but
I told, I told them that and they're like, you know, Hey, it is what it is.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
And I totally get that.
Um, but yeah, I don't know that I would have ever done it, but Mariah said, dude, you know,
you're making more money hacking part-time than you are at your main job full-time.
So this doesn't make any sense.
Um, and then, yeah, so at that point we've kind of pulled the trigger.
And at that time, uh, when I switched to full-time bug bounty, I was moving to Japan.
So the healthcare problem was sort of solved by being a student, uh, at a language school in
Japan and getting healthcare through the government there.
Um, and yeah, it's kind of worked like, like that ever since.
So, so I'm curious why maybe you could give me some background about what made you choose
to do the switch instead of if you're already making more than you're making at your full-time
job, why not keep the full-time job as just passive stable income and then make the majority
of your income on the side doing, you know, basically a hobby.
Yeah, that's a great question.
And I think I, I, um, I've actually advised a couple of my friends that are like, Hey, should
I go full-time bug bounty?
Um, to keep their, their full-time jobs, especially if it's cush, you know, there are some security
gigs that are just chill AF out there, you know, they really are.
And they pay, they do not pay a nominal amount of money.
Um, I was not, I was not making super much.
I was making 70 base when I, when I came out of college.
Um, and, uh, and so, you know, there are some people over on, on the West coast, you know,
in the mid, you know, in the 200 range.
And I'm like, I wouldn't leave that job if I were you, you know?
Um, and so, uh, yeah, I, I think it's relative.
And for me, um, when I was hacking part-time, it was taking a lot of, it was taking all of
my free time and it was, you know, putting it into this money-making hobby, which was
great.
And I, and I, and I enjoyed the hobby.
Um, but also I wanted to be able to do other things with my free time as well.
And, you know, just more things with my time than just security.
So shifting bug bounty to my main income allowed me to still kill it in bug bounty, have fun
and, um, you know, participate in that community while also being able to, you know, I just went
and played pickleball for a couple hours or before we started this podcast and I do a podcast
and spend time with my wife and friends.
So that's kind of, that's kind of the main goal to get time back.
Yeah.
So about, uh, speaking about like the time stuff, I know we talked a little bit about how
much you work each day and all that kind of stuff.
Yeah.
Outside of live hacking events, do you hack on weekends?
Is it weekdays only?
Um, it depends.
So, you know, because I'm not limited to a traditional schedule, sometimes I'll, you know, my weekend
will be Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, and, you know, we'll go do a trip or something like
that when no one else is around and, you know, while the, the lines are short or the, you
know, the crowds aren't there, which is great.
And then in those scenarios, I will work on weekends sometimes, but, um, I definitely try
to avoid working on Sunday.
That's sort of a, a, um, a Christian principle.
And I think it's really wise, whether you're a Christian or not, is, uh, is just having
one day set aside for rest.
That's just like holy to you, you know, that's just like, you don't infringe upon that because,
um, at least for me, I, I'm definitely stray more on the side of like, I want to work more.
I want to work.
I want to push it, push it, push it, push it.
Right.
And so having one day that's just kind of like, no, this day is a day where we sit on our couch
and read a book, or we sit in the hot tub and, you know, chill versus hacking.
I think that's been a big value for me.
Got it.
So if you're taking time off, um, it's a little bit of a complicated relationship because you
are both the employee and the employer, right?
Yeah.
Everything is relying on you.
And I had a lot of this struggle when I was in college, but essentially doing bug bounty
full-time where I got to a point where I, I felt like I was being like a very aggressive
boss towards myself, essentially where I was like, I have to be working.
I have to be right.
And how do you balance that where you get to take time off, but you don't want to feel
bad about taking time off?
Well, I've got this great boss, Mariah, who, uh, says, who's very much like, dude, if
I'm a workaholic, she is like, just so able to, if I'm being a workaholic, she is so able
to just shut that down and like slap me out of it and just be like, dude, what are you
doing?
Like, no, we're about to go take a trip.
And like, it's going to be a blast.
This is, this is, you know, this is why we made this decision.
And so, um, I definitely struggle with that.
I definitely struggle with being like, ah, I gotta, I gotta get back to work.
I gotta, I gotta work.
But then she just reminds me, you know, like, no, you don't.
And you can come and chill and do this.
And, uh, you know, I've been doing it for just, actually it's three years this month, um, that
I've been full-time bug bounty.
Um, and, uh, yeah, I'm just kind of now getting the swing of like being able to pretty guilt-free
be like, yeah, okay.
You know what?
I'm off, you know, and that's how it is.
And, and I'll pick up the slack a different day or I'll write on the slack of, uh, provided
by, you know, the last live hacking event or whatever.
Got it.
Do you, um, do you ever feel like you get burned out or overworked doing it full-time?
Yeah.
I mean, it's definitely a danger.
Um, I kind of talked a little bit about this, um, in the, in a panel with HackerOne, um, a
while back, but, um, for me, oh, burnout and overwork comes from when I, it mostly comes
from when I try to put my identity in my work and then I, I don't fulfill it.
So if I am aiming for one, you know, number one for NVH at a live hacking event, and then
I get like 12th or like 20th or something like, in those scenarios, that's when I feel like, you
know what, I just, I'm burnout on this.
Like I tried my best and I can't, you know, do anything.
Um, and so for me, you know, having shifted my, and I did that for a long time and there
was a period when I strongly considered quitting bug bounty, um, right after I had first started
going full-time.
Um, but then I, you know, I realized, Hey, you know, my, my self-worth is found in other
things besides my work performance.
Uh, for me, it's, it's found in the love of Jesus for others that have done it successfully.
It's, it's found in relationships.
It's found in, you know, living their best life that they can and, and to each their own.
Um, but, uh, yeah, I think if you've got your, you know, your identity, you're not putting
your identity in your work and you're, you're setting reasonable boundaries.
Obviously, you know, you can't be doing three months of 12, 14 hour days without feeling some
stuff, but I do it for, you know, three weeks to a month when prepping for live hacking
events.
And it's still pretty manageable as long as I keep my communication up with my spouse
and I, um, and I, you know, I, I don't do 16 hour days, you know, and I still got a couple
hours on either side to chill and communicate and see touch grass, you know?
Yeah.
So it sounds like you do set goals to some extent then, but it's sort of like manageable
ones, right?
You don't want to be like, I want to be number one because then if you don't hit number one,
then it's really, it feels bad, right?
Yeah.
Goal management, I think is pretty, is pretty fuzzy for me.
Um, I definitely do sit down and say, all right, you know, this is where I'd like my income
goals to be for a year and for a month and stuff like that.
And for a live hacking event, I don't set, um, I set financial goals for a live hacking
event, which is really fun.
And I don't know if I mentioned this to you before, Joel, but actually Mariah started, uh,
helping me figure out this system.
Um, she said, Hey, okay, we're going to set a goal, let's say, you know, 20 grand or whatever.
And, uh, for every, you know, tick above that goal, um, you get a prize.
Oh, okay.
And so, uh, you know, if I do instead of 20 grand, I do 30 grand, then, you know, I I'll
get, you know, like, I don't know what's a good example.
One of, one of my, one of my prizes, this is the high, the highest prize was a hot tub,
which I talk about all the time because I use it, you know, all the time.
And all of my friends just keep their bathing suits in their car now.
Cause whenever they come over, we're hopping into the hot tub, they know it.
Um, uh, and that was, you know, the highest tier and that's been great.
And we've done some work on our house patio and stuff like that.
Um, and so, yeah, having those sort of tiered goals from a financial perspective is very motivating.
Um, and yeah, besides that, I'm not really, I don't really set first place, second place,
third place, MVH, you know, goals anymore, because, um, I think those are, are largely,
um, variable based off of who else is around, who's hacking, how much time they're putting
in and that sort of thing as well.
Got it.
Um, so let's see.
Yeah.
Let's talk about taxes first and then we'll get on more of a technical side.
So, um, sort of on the business side, taxes, healthcare, all that kind of stuff.
How do you manage, cause I think most people know bug bounty income is not taxed from hacker
one or bug crowd or whoever's paying it.
It's just, they just said you lump some money and it's kind of up to you to figure it out.
So do you have a, like an automated system or any like system in general that you use to
manage your taxes and all that kind of financial side of, I guess, the business?
Yeah.
So go ahead and throw out the preface out there.
Not, not tax advice, not legal advice, not health insurance advice.
Boom.
Disclaimed.
Safe.
Um, yeah, safe, very professional.
Um, for taxes, I have an LLC, which is structured as an S corp.
And, um, I, I kind of do it that way.
And you can talk to your accountants about the way that, um, that you can do that in, in
America.
It's a pretty common, um, tax optimization setup.
Um, I pay myself a salary, um, through the company and I also issue, um, dividends to
myself or maybe the technical term isn't dividends, but I also pull money out as the
owner of the company.
Um, and then I'm also able to employ my wife as well.
Um, so, uh, that's, that's a great way to get value, uh, from the taxes perspective.
And I think to be perfectly honest, just sitting down and paying the big bill that it, that it
takes to get a good accountant to sit down with you, um, is very, very worth it for anyone
who's looking to go into a bug bounty.
Um, I've been really impressed with my accountant's work.
So definitely, definitely do that.
Yeah.
I have an accountant too.
I, uh, yeah, I, he's awesome.
Uh, I'm not going to say his name cause I want him all to myself, but, uh, but yeah, no, find
yourself a good accountant, ask some friends for recommendations or something.
But, um, an accountant is definitely more, it's worth more than whatever you're going
to pay for it.
Oh yeah.
The advice is just priceless.
Yeah, for sure.
Cool.
And then from the, from the healthcare perspective, I'll just hop on that really quick.
Um, we are, yeah, we're at like 57 minutes right now.
So, um, we gotta, we gotta, I won't go, I won't talk about this for too long, but my blog
post, um, I, I did do a blog post on hacker healthcare.
Um, and it's, it's a pretty, it's a pretty good post, um, sort of outlining my setup for
healthcare.
Uh, it talks about how I have sort of two areas that I've, two ways that I've solved this
problem in the U S one is catastrophic coverage.
So if I were to like get cancer or like get hit by a car and break like 30 bones, um, how
is that getting paid for?
And for me, that's covered by a health share plan, um, which you can read about on the,
on the blog, very affordable.
I think it's $182 a month for me and Mariah or something like that.
And then I also, the other side of it is, um, the sort of day to day care, um, which is
like, you know, Hey, I'm sick.
I need a prescription.
Hey, I've got a really bad case of poison Ivy from digging around in the weeds in my backyard.
Help.
Um, maybe that one was a little too, too, too clear, too specific.
You called on some memories.
Triggered.
Um, no, uh, and you know, then for that, I have a, um, DPC subscription, which is a direct
primary care subscription, which is essentially a contract I've set up with a doctor that, um,
you know, he, I can just text him and call him and video chat and pretty much just walk
into the office whenever I feel like it.
And he's there available to be, to be seen and to answer any questions.
And man, that is some serious value, you know?
Yeah.
I think everybody I know who's self-employed is paying like five times that at least.
It's crazy.
So, I mean, it's only, it's 182 for me and Mariah for the, um, for the, uh, catastrophic
care.
And then the, the, the subscription every month is like a hundred bucks for a purpose and
for the doctor.
So it's definitely worth it.
We get out, you know, quite cheap with that and we get really high quality of care.
So I was really, really grateful to have found a good solution because healthcare is
so stressful in the United States and that seems a good way.
Yeah.
Cool.
Okay.
Last question, not on the business side.
Uh, how do you, how do you like organize yourself?
Um, you're doing all this hacking, you're hacking like pretty much every day for many
hours a day.
How do you map out an application?
How do you take notes?
How do you keep track of different programs?
How do you, how do you structure it?
Well, um, this, this really cool friend of mine named Joel introduced me to VS Code.
Oh, you gotta introduce me to that guy.
Yeah.
What, what I, what I do is I, uh, pop open a VS Code instance and then I
spam random keys and save a file and then I just put random notes in there on like IDs and
like weird pieces of JavaScript that I like or something like that.
Um, unfortunately I'm not a terribly organized, uh, hacker.
My, um, you know, I do name my burp tabs.
Um, I do name my burp tabs, but I'm also not taking very structured notes, unfortunately,
um, on the targets.
Um, at this point in my progression as a hacker, um, I kinda, this is gonna sound really, you
know, uh, weird, but I just kinda go with the flow of the application.
You know, like I'm, I'm really just kind of trying to live in the application and, you
know, kind of, kind of figure out how it feels.
Um, and, and so taking notes, taking structured notes beyond, you know, something that I want
to be able to go back and grab really quick and paste in, um, is not something that I, that
I do super well.
Um, I know a lot of people do, but I don't.
And, um, one, one tip just, uh, on my methodology that was a total game changer for me lately was
a friend of mine, non-technical friend.
Um, she, she showed me lately that you can, Windows has a built-in clipboard history.
Oh yeah.
I've, I pulled this up by, I have pulled this up by accident, like so many times.
It's like Windows, Windows.
Is it Windows V, I think?
Windows C or Windows, yeah, it's Windows V.
Windows C is Cortana.
Yeah, Windows V, man, I love this.
And then you can just scroll through and like see a history.
So this is my note taking now, like my Windows V is my note taking.
All of the IDs are in there, like all the sketchy pieces of JavaScript, all the endpoints,
you know, it's all in there.
Um, and I don't know, man, like I told you, I was kind of unsure about switching to, to
WSL, Windows Subsystem for Linux, but I do like that one piece.
And if I ever go back to Linux, I'm definitely going to find some sort of
similar solution for Linux.
Yeah.
Okay.
Dude, that's awesome.
I think we're out of time.
All right.
Yeah.
That's a wrap, um, for the main section, um, on full-time bug bounty.
Um, I guess, tell you what, I'll go ahead and cut the recording here and then we'll, um,
I'll go ahead and pull Kodai and Soma on to talk about their bugs and, uh, we'll just
splice it together.
That's all good.
Yeah.
I'm, I'm super pumped for those who don't know.
I don't know if we talked about this, but you, two people that you've mentored, you're
going to be bringing on and, uh, they're going to be talking about some bugs that they found,
which is super, super dope.
Should be, should be really fun.
Um, any, any closing thoughts or is that a wrap?
Uh, this has made me think really hard about bug bounty full-time and all that kind of
stuff, you know, um, in my own personal perspective on joy in the dark side, time management and
energy management and all that kind of stuff.
I think the, the closing advice I'll give is, um, I think one of the things I've noticed
throughout life is that it's all about energy management and finding the best way to manage
your energy is like the key to everything else.
So just finding like what motivates you, how to set those goals and keep it healthy.
Um, but also being able to push yourself, uh, I think you do a really awesome job at, at
all of that.
And, uh, I, I definitely strive to be, be closer to that.
Thanks, man.
I appreciate it.
Yeah.
Those, those are some deep thoughts to leave people off with, but definitely, definitely,
uh, something to, to be considered.
And yeah, you know, energy is, is definitely a, um, is definitely a cool thing to optimize for
because I think there's so many people that optimize for money, a lot of people that optimize
for time.
Um, but yeah, optimizing for energy is, is definitely, definitely something to consider.
So with that, with that, we'll, uh, we'll cut it here and we'll switch over to some, uh,
bug reports from, uh, Kodai and Soma.
Um, yeah.
Awesome.
Thanks for listening.
Talk to you next week.
See ya.
Sweet.
We're rolling.
Sup guys.
Welcome to the show.
Hey.
Thank you.
We've, uh, we've got my two, my two mentees, Kodai and Soma here.
Um, I have the mic shifted further away from my super loud voice, um, closer to them to pick
theirs up.
Um, pretty much just going to have you guys talk today about the two bugs that we selected,
um, that you found kind of when we were working together.
Um, they're pretty great bugs.
I'm, I'm really proud of them.
I met these two.
So actually, let me, let me give a disclaimer before we get into this episode.
Um, I do not take mentorship, mentee applications.
I, the last time I mentioned it on air, 15 people messaged me and were like, hey, anytime,
you know, I only do this for like friends, great guys like these guys that I know in real
life.
Um, so, uh, I will keep you up to date about whether that ever changes, but for right now,
um, no, no, no mentorship program.
So, um, all right, guys, you ready to roll?
Which one of you guys wants to go first?
Um, I can go first.
All right, Kodai, hit us.
Um, hello everyone.
My name is Kodai.
I also go by the name of Kodai Chodai, which is my, my, uh, silly hacker handle.
Nice.
Yeah.
Um, so Kodai is my name and Chodai means like in Japanese, like, give me, give me something.
It's a sort of vibe.
Um, I think you were the one that actually like came up with that.
We, we forced him, we, he couldn't come up with a name for his hacker one handle.
So when we were setting it up, we were like, all right, it's going to be Kodai Chodai, which
is a, a saying that Mariah came up with one night when we were doing board game night or something
like that.
Yeah.
So he's stuck with it forever now because he's already found some bugs.
So he's not going to ditch that rep.
I kind of regretted it.
Yeah.
Well, uh, so I graduated from college.
So I'm at this point where, um, I'm not really sure if I'm allowed to introduce myself as a hacker.
Honestly.
Yes, you are.
You're about to talk about a bug on a podcast.
Absolutely, man.
So, yeah, that's about it, I guess.
Yeah.
Are you, are you, um, I mean, do you think you want to focus primarily on bug bounty, uh,
from here on out?
Are you, you entertaining an employment options or what?
Uh, that's a great question.
Um, yeah, so I'm still kind of sitting on the fence, you know, trying to decide, uh, which
direction I should go to.
And, uh, yeah, I don't know, man, but I think at the end of the day, what I really want to
do is, um, bug hunting, like, full time.
Yeah.
It gives you that flexibility and, yeah.
That's good, man.
All right, Soma, you want to give a little introduction as well?
Yeah, sure.
Um, I'm Soma.
I'm doing hacking with my name of Matope.
Matope.
Anomatope.
Onomatope.
Which is a nickname from Japanese.
Yeah.
Basically, and I am a, I was a student until February.
I just, thank you.
Yeah.
I just, yeah, finished my bachelor's degree in chemistry and, in computer science, I've
been working on my, like, own mini projects, doing some programming and that kind of stuff.
Yeah, yeah, that's, that's great.
Yeah, I remember, so, Soma and I met through a mutual friend and he was studying chemistry
and I was like, oh, that's cool.
And then we, we talked about it a little bit more and he's like, yeah, but look at this
cool, like, line bot that I wrote and stuff like that.
Yeah, and he had done, he had done a bunch of really cool IT stuff on the side.
Um, so, yeah, I was really impressed and, and where are you, where are you working?
Well, now that you've graduated.
Yeah, from April, from next, this April, I'm gonna start working for a company called
Rakuten, which is a pretty big company in Japan.
Yeah, it's one of the biggest, uh, you know, it's, it's competitor to Amazon in Japan.
So, really thrilled for you that you nailed that interview and got that one.
Thanks.
That's a really great job.
Um, so, yeah, I hope you'll continue doing bug bounty, uh, in your free time on the side
and, yeah.
I will, I definitely will.
That sounds good.
All right, so, the bugs, right?
Um, do you guys need your laptops or are you just gonna, just kind of wing it?
Um.
Good?
Good to just talk about it?
I think I'm good.
All right, so, uh, Kodai went first doing intros, so maybe Soma wants to go first doing
the bug explanations.
Sure.
All right, hit us.
Yeah, so, I was hacking a Japanese app.
Uh, a very famous American company, and I was looking into strings.xml.
So, this is an Android app?
Android app, yeah, and then I found this parameter called Kagi, which is, um, ki in Japanese, and
they used this parameter to decode other hard-coded, like, really important, um, information.
Um, and, I think other hackers couldn't find this because it's, you know, it's in Japanese,
and I was able to find that because I'm a Japanese, and, yeah, yeah, this is one thing
I like about hacking.
Um, so, you kind of, like, you kind of utilized many information.
Yeah.
For example, like, HTTP, and then web app, you used Linux server.
And languages.
Yeah, and then new natural language, too.
Yeah.
Which is really cool.
Yeah, that was such a fun, fun bug.
We couldn't believe when we saw the string was, like, Kagi.
It was literally just ki in Japanese.
And then it just decrypted everything that they had secret in the app.
So, that was a really good find, Soma.
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, and you, you, like, um, you typically go, I guess you've got more experience with
mobile apps than web application hacking, yeah?
Yeah.
Yeah, so that, that should definitely be good for you, and I think, yeah, we've got some
targets we're working on right now that are, are really exciting.
Not, not, uh, not mobile, actually, where you're focusing on, uh, another, I guess we, we can't
really say the company name because the bug isn't even submitted yet, but you've got, uh,
another bug in the works, yeah?
Yeah.
Yeah, should be, should be really fun.
It's a CSS injection.
Yeah, CSS injection and credit card, um, post message.
Yeah, credit card, post message, CSS injection, it's gonna be a great bug, dude.
I'm really excited.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Kodai, you're up next.
What are you talking about?
Sure.
Um, so I'm gonna talk about this, um, numeric IDOR that me and Justin actually collaborated
on.
Um, so one time, um, we were hacking this food delivery service, and when you open up the page
logged in, um, on the top left-hand corner, you see this little pin-looking mark, and if
you clicked on that it shows, um, a couple of interesting pieces of user information and, uh,
uh, such as, um, drivers, driver instructions, um, zip code, you know, the whole address of
the user and stuff.
Um, and so we thought, okay, this is really interesting, so we should, you know, we, so basically, we decided
to, um, poke around it a little bit.
Um, and we found out that the user, uh, no, the server, on the server side, the server
wasn't validating the user through any secure methodologies, but what the server was actually
doing is that it was validating the user through this, um, 10-digit value.
Mm-hmm.
So it was all numeric.
And, so, yeah, we basically, um...
And this was in the, this was in the address change functionality, right?
Yeah.
So you, you saw those, that delivery instruction, zip code, the address, and then there was a
functionality to change that, and the request that it was, it was sending to the server, it
was only validating which users, or which address should be changed via that, via that numeric
ID, right?
Yeah.
That numeric ID.
So it was, um, the numeric ID was, um, at least on the website, called, um, address ID.
Mm-hmm.
So we decided to, um, change the address ID to see, um, if the modified malicious user input
that we created, um, will be reflected on the victim's account.
Mm-hmm.
So we decided that, um, just modifying the, the request body of, uh, GraphQL.
Uh, post request.
Yeah.
That's right.
But, uh, we actually didn't see any result on the request, uh, res- yeah, on the HTTP response.
Right.
So, but we still try to, um, go to the website and see the results.
Mm-hmm.
This is really, this is really key, guys.
This is a good, this is a good piece here.
So, talk, talk about that.
Yeah.
So we didn't really see the, see, we didn't see anything, um, any change on the HTTP response.
Mm-hmm.
But we did see the change, the malicious user input reflected on the victim's page.
Ah.
Yeah.
That's how we, yeah.
So, so what you were saying was that there was an IDOR, and with, with regarding to change
the address for a specific user, you could, you could specify a different address for a different
user.
And, uh, that, that occurred when you send the request, the response, it, what I mean, was it
an error?
It was an error, right?
Yeah.
It was 500 error.
Ah.
Okay.
So it was a 500 error as a, a, a server error, right?
So it's not a 403.
It's not an access denied.
It's a 500 server error, but it's still updated.
Yeah.
On the victim's page.
It's a good one, man.
That's a good one.
So look out for that guys, where you, um, where you're, uh, testing an IDOR and even
if you get an access denied, or even if you get a, you know, 500 server error back, that
doesn't mean that the attack didn't take effect.
Um, so always validate that your IDOR didn't actually take effect, um, on the, on the victim
account and also check, and, and maybe just use inputs that are kind of crazy.
So in this scenario, maybe could, I could have changed the address of, um, you know, somebody
to say, you know, yeah, this is, you know, crazy input.
And then, you know, when you're going into that account, if you look at the address in
the future, you can say, oh, wait a second.
That actually did take effect.
So those are some great, those are some great tips.
Good stuff guys.
Um, any, any takeaways from this you want to share with the, with the crowd?
Yeah.
So, so from my bug, I'd say I already mentioned a little bit, but you know, you can like use
a lot of knowledge for hacking.
And, um, it's not just about vulnerabilities, but you can use your, um, natural language knowledge
and also like cryptography and programming too.
Yeah.
And, and yeah, I learned that from that bug that I found.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
So taking, uh, areas from taking information from a lots of different areas and everyone's,
everyone's a unique hacker.
Everyone has their own perspective from which they're hacking.
Um, so that can definitely give you a unique perspective and help you to find bugs that other
people can't find.
So that's a great takeaway.
Kodai, what about you?
Um, I'd say, um, numerical IDORS could, uh, they, they're really super impactful.
Yeah.
They're very impactful.
Um, so you should definitely, you know, uh, go after that.
And, and you know, just like you said, sometimes you don't really see the results that you would
like to see on the, um, HTTP response, but definitely, you know, maybe like by trying to
make it look a little more, um, obvious, uh, you can, yeah, you should definitely try to
see it on the, the, the victim account.
The victim account.
Yeah.
That makes total sense.
Sweet guys.
Thanks for coming on and sharing.
I kind of, I kind of forced him into this a little bit.
Um, but yeah, I think that's, I think that's it for the episode.
Hope you guys enjoyed and, uh, we'll see you again next week.
All right.
See everybody.